Obama dear pal to Bombardier we are
nearing our target open the bay doors
and prepare to the page to mama dear is
there a problem Hey Jude had to Papa
dear hows about here is the payload
malfunctioning you're not functioning
all you want to do is talk about your
pops I've got a bum for you i hate you
too mama dear the mission is at stake
what's the status of the payload what's
the status her I'm surprised you can't
see it on your precious radar pilots a
mama dear I've had a lot of things on my
mind lately well apparently I am NOT one
of those things that's mama dear it's
not you it's me we are nearing the
target open the banco para tu mama dear
we're going back around for a second
dependence the target you don't get it
do you can't change the past so just try
I m'dear just tell me what you want me
to do and I will do it what I want I
want a real person I don't want to lose
group to man probably a positive over
there I'm not psychic I can't read your
mind I'm not asking you to be second I'm
just asking you to understand me all
right we used to understand each other
we did before the drinking tomorrow i've
had them over there you're right I'm
sorry would you say that it was you
either hi mama dear i love you
I love you too pilot why don't you
release the payload and come to the
cockpit so we can talk like we used to
that sounds nice bay doors open arms
away